M it's
God it's
God it's God this is a peaceful Islam
that uh so I was showing this one here
this is this is this was
yesterday they
killed they killed the Christian guy
look at that he he's already dead he's
already dead and they were still hitting
him because somebody they saying that
they um they made a false statement that
somebody B thean but he did not I think
that was his son but they killed the
father for innocent God it's so sad yeah
it's unfortunate it's not unfortunate
this is the way Islam is that's not how
Islam is where are you from Pakistan
where in Pakistan are you from Karachi
Karachi do you see what happens in India
when it comes to Muslims from Hindus
tell me what happened do you do you have
you heard about what happened in Assam
to the Muslims in India tell what
happened how can you like no no I told
you that what happened you tell me what
happened the Muslims are beat up every
single day in India for eating beef for
being kill for reading Quran they're
they have to read the Indian um their
Anthem in schools that openly is against
Muslims why did we have the partition in
the first
place and she's Indian so like she knows
how it goes every she probably doesn't
know that I mean how do you know that
that's what happens in do you ever live
in India like I've been to India my
parents are from India yeah parents and
there that's a different story that's
I'm saying she does not know the real I
mean I I don't want to do a Islamic
study in Pakistan but they force me to
do it they don't force you to do Islamic
stud in Pakistan I'm from
Pakistan pakan you telling me I study
from there yeah you don't have to give
the exam you don't have to you you have
to study in school and that's about it
you don't have to give the exam but in
the United States and India you have
you're forced to take religion yeah so
that's that's what I'm trying to tell
you that's a law of the land and that's
the country rules and you have to follow
it but if you go against the the country
rules me I'm a Christian I can eat the
pork okay people they eat pork what you
think they going to allow me in Pakistan
people in India aren't allowed to eat
I'm talking about Pakistan look I'm not
from India I'm talking about Pakistan so
if I eat the pork in Pakistan they will
allow me they're not going to stop you
from what you do we're not allowed to do
something based off the law see that's
exactly what is happening to India you
telling they they believe they God okay
the call they are worshiping Okay so you
are doing something in front of them
they might be not going to like it the
same thing like if I do fork in Pakistan
they're going to hit me for that and
they kill me look at what
happening do you know how many other
murders happen around the world every
have you heard of what's happening in
Palestine what do you think of what's
happening in Palestine that's all
politics that's not politics this is all
politics I I think I think what he's
getting to is that because there could
be people who do bad things in each
religion but what he's saying is that
this is actually it's something that's
taught in Islam like it's not taught in
Islam where in Islam is a Tau let's kill
the it's not Tau if you have hold on I
can show
you um and so do you guys speak Arabic
at all no how did you just assume I
didn't speak Arabic you can recite the
Quran I know you're from Pakistan you
can read Arabic I know that okay sister
you look you are from my country I know
I'm aware but how did you just assume I
can't be okay read let let me ask you
something to read the Quran I like I
like her don't let don't let him get
away with nothing get him you okay I'm
ask you for that okay the meaning of it
okay let's see I'm going to ask you that
so do you want to do you want to do that
first or you want to show the show me
what you need show all right all right
so so this is chapter N9 the Surah Toba
uh verse 29 okay um here it is up here
so it says fight against those who
believe not in Allah nor in the last day
nor forbid that which has been forbidden
by Allah and his Messenger right
Muhammad and those who acknowledge not
the religion of Truth I.E Islam among
the people of the scripture Jews and
Christians until they pay the gizia with
willing submission and fill themselves
themselves subdue do you know when this
verse was revealed yes when was it
revealed it it was revealed after
Muhammad had conquered Arabia it was
revealed after Muhammad was conquered
Arabia after three different attempts
were given to the Jews in the area of Y
in Medina at that time to make sure that
they would either pay the Jia or leave
the land because they were causing
trouble in that land however beyond that
they had
CA they they had sided with the side of
m al kazab the false prophet do you know
why though why what do you know why they
sided against Muhammad because they
didn't believe him as as a prophet at
the end of the day though the Jews were
not native to yth they did not own that
land about the Christians the Christians
are also not native to yth I
mean but why does he the Romans at that
time were also Conquering the Muslim
empire the Romans conquered the Muslim
empire no they wasn't Cesar the um the
Persian and the Roman Empire were
fighting
you Pi yeah the Persians and the Romans
were fighting that's true and the
Persians and the Romans were fighting
and then they thought Muslims were a
threat and so then when Costo came to
kill the prophet sallallahu alhi
wasallam in their battle they went and
they fought each other and so it wasn't
until the ninth year of the Hijra when
that Surah when that Ayah was revealed
after the Jews had attack tried
attacking them it didn't say the Jews
attacked them no not they didn't try to
attack Muhammad after the ninth uh the
ninth year of the H at that point they
had conquered yth they had the Muslims
hadu rule over y they had caused issues
with Hypocrites mhm they had caused
issues with the um the locals of Medina
they had start they started
controversies with the local um tribes
in Medina at the time yeah but they
wasn't at war with the Muslims they
weren't at War either but you know the
context of the Su yes so look so even if
you go into the top SE like IB he lays
it all out after Muhammad beat all the
polytheist in Arabia conquered all of
Arabia then this verse came saying now
go and fight the people of the book the
Jews and the Christians now in the area
that they had conquered for anything
Empire also Char but do you know what
the jiz ISL I know what tax that's
charged to non-muslims to live in a land
to do but what is the what is the
purpose of the gizia to make sure you
either follow the land follow follow the
rule of the land or you become Muslim
it's one of the two no the purpose of
the gizia is to show the humiliation of
the nonl that is not the purpose of the
gizia oh can I show you that's what your
Scholars say it's not me I promise I can
show you from the toer I can show you I
let me show you this what I says he says
the Jizzy is to show The Continuous
humiliation and the belittlement of the
the non-muslim of the people of the book
because they reject Muhammad notice this
isn't about them fighting against
Muhammad it's fight those who don't
believe yeah because what does to mean
believing in the Oneness of Allah you
live in one land you live in a country
that is made for example when the
Muslims lived in ABIA we paid taxes we
were law-abiding citizens and we had to
take part of the elections that didn't
mean that the Muslims were
um just sitting there and doing whatever
and like following their own religion
that's not true you can't live in any
land and not have to partake in the the
local customs and traditions that's how
things work so look if we have here
you're saying that in the land right
that you have to pay the gizia you have
to do that y y y and follow the laws of
the land but according to
this according to this they're
conquering other lands not their own the
Muslims are going outside of their own
land and going into neighboring lands
and conquering them and then forcing the
Jizzy on them do you see what I'm saying
that's like me coming to your home right
beating you up and making you submit and
pay to
Me video yeah we already know smile on
camera you on camera too for running
away they're they're more men than you
are to have a conversation it's crazy
anyway so what do you think the
Christians did dis constant Nole did
disbelief they disbelief in I'm going
come and talk to you in Islam No no no
what did they do when they conquered uh
when they illegally raped and conquered
all of South Africa what do they do in
Africa what do in Europe what did they
do when they killed everyone in Spain
when Muslims had conquered Spain 500
years beforehand and then the Spaniards
came and the the Romans came and they
went and they killed and raped all those
people in Spain but you guys have
nothing to defend about that have
questions say we we do watch notice how
I'm going to deal with you right or deal
with this issue not you the issue
because I notice how I said that we're
talking about not what bad people do
within a religion right we're not
looking at Muslims and saying look at
these Muslims they're bad they're going
against their religion no we're saying
that this this violence is taught in the
religion the vi look let me say that I
grant you that they were that these
people who were wait let me say this gr
anything yes well yes I am let me say
this I'm saying if I were to give it to
you that these so-called Christians
right we're going out you know raping
pillaging and all that kind of stuff
that goes directly against what the
Bible says okay directly now what we're
we're talking about what does the source
teach right does Islam teach and and and
allow the violence against non-muslims
or is the book against it so my our
point is is that according to the Quran
it actually allows that type of action
it allows that have you read the Quran
where it says in multiple occasions
treat your neighbors with peace treat
those of with peace when the prophet
moved to for the first time why did he
not in enact any sort of I I can say
good good question that's a beautiful
question let me answer it because I'm
asking you well you asked me so I got to
answer you talking to you but you asked
me a question I didn't ask you a
question
okay go ahead I didn't ask you so didn't
you literally just say why didn't
Muhammad do this at the time go ahead
I'm listening to though he moved because
he wanted to have a peaceful
relationship with the Jews in the area
there was three different types of
Jewish tribes in the area you cannot
shake your head on something you don't
know about I'm teaching you your
religion but you don't know I'm teaching
My Religion which I know well but you
don't know this you didn't you didn't
know that Muhammad was going outside of
his other of his own lands where okay so
how do you think he conquered Pakistan
so is that okay is it okay to yes that's
how every religion spread no not
Christianity Christianity was look
Christianity was the minority
Christianity was the one getting
attacked by by the Romans getting
getting pillaged and they it was small
they they spread by the by faith and by
their action you all didn't spread by
your faith or your actions spread by
fake first of all the Christianity you
guys follow isn't even actual authentic
Christianity it was Christianity made
500 years after the death of the Prophet
Esa how much
yeah so look if you you can say that but
that's not dealing with the point the
issue is what do our religions teach and
so you're not dealing with the argument
that the religion of Islam teaches to go
and subjugate those who disbelieve you
have to deal with that in one specific
context of the Quran I can pull up an
equal passage on the Bible and do the
exact same thing do it I'm not going to
sit here and argue I'm not sitting here
and being like Oh my God Christianity is
a wrong religion Prophet Muhammad's
daughter Prophet blah blah that doesn't
it's because you can't I can do this
with your Quran because I've read it and
I know what your religion teaches you
can't do that to the Bible because you
one you don't know what the Bible says
and two it doesn't you could say that
it's not that's an authentic Testament
you have to change the Old Testament
change the New Testament and you guys
have no actual credibility that the
issue ask me a question about one of
these things that you have back here uh
how about this I'll ask you a question
we have a other side it says prove that
Jesus was a Muslim you believe Jesus was
a Muslim I believe Jesus is a prophet of
Allah do you believe he wasl not
revealed at that time what he taught yes
was a message of Islam do you believe he
was a Muslim I believe that Jesus Jesus
is a prophet of Allah so is that a yes
or no yeah he was muslim okay why do you
think he was a Muslim because he was
taught the religion of Allah at the end
of the day at that time it wasn't Islam
it wasn't Christianity it wasn't Judaism
it was just Islam so why would you say
he was a Muslim if it wasn't Muslim back
there isn't that a logical question I
don't think there's any point
discussion anymore we yeah let's go well
I appreciate you like seriously I
appreciate the conversation that's
it the cop ofran you guys don't have
Quran sorry not have original you know
in Islam we believe that our Quran is
original is
okay thank you so much sister please
please look to this 929 okay country
thank you godess you look for Jesus okay
that's the only way
that was
awesome good one yeah that was awesome
I'll send you this one you got to get
the direct
face oh my God logic
[Music]